what is going on there citizens the
reject Nation how's it going John I am
great I'm so excited how are you doing
great thank you we are going to continue
Andor today with episode 3 Revenge of
the Jedi I'm excited because the last
two episodes have been great so far you
can catch your reactions they're up here
on the channel right now also don't
forget to leave a like use the force
please that I mean the world subscribe
and click the notification Bell to get
notified when a reaction for F4 is up
here on the channel as always full
length and watch along as we sync up
with your own copy meaning there's a
Time code involved I know some of you
are still going to go there and be like
I don't understand what's happening with
this video
full show pirated for me oh I forgot to
watch the longest available for super
sexy rejects over at our patreon page
but we do cover some shows over there
exclusively the same tier reaction
highlights and watch alongs included as
well the Museum of prepper you guys are
doing a good job
keep it up
I'll reward you with a peanut m m
orry
[Music]
abandoned and Imperial mining disaster
everyone died what was the Empire mining
kyber crystals or something the force
though we're mining the force those
precious Force veins deep in the Earth
this young and or has such cool hair I
was just thinking always perfectly in
his face
look like potatoes
that's what they're mining for potatoes
have you never seen your reflection
before maybe not in like uh actual like
glass yeah
or could just be he felt like a failure
pay more enforcement put out a bulletin
last night for someone meeting
cap I don't think many people know
you killed these men on Madonna you guys
are talking loudly
you trusted
he'll be there
I suspect he's a big part of the
Rebellion
I love the perspective shots
so well done this really does put you in
space
in a different way
are we satisfied
are you listening it's safe whatever it
was it's burned off just get your mask
off
[Music]
oh [ __ ] well done yes I was like damn
she's a badass I guess get me the
drowser
no mother no shut up then he's got
people here yeah people have just killed
a republican officer it'll be open
season here at the moment that figured
land
oh
you better think about this
plenty of time for that I'm not leaving
I'm here to die oh I like where the
mirroring of this is going when he meets
with Skarsgard it's like the destiny of
it all
this is so freaking cool the way we're
doing this
some of the best two like forward and
backward and time jumping I've seen in a
while we have a warrant for Cassie and
Andor
[Music]
check the shelves he might be there
under these trinkets
where's Cassian Droid
Marvel plus power supply no don't let
them scare you be they can't do that
corporate we can do want
be are you back yet ah
I want you to tell Marva that I'm sorry
you know how cool she gets East North
East got it leave one man here are you
ready
to stay here are you hearing me keep an
eye on them
oh damn we're gonna have our first big
shootout
you made it
oh we're alone
I am hmm the moment I plug it in the
value drops so you could be scamming me
you know where I live so I could come
back if I were dissatisfied I speaks
ever burned you before
you're planning on sticking around are
you
you have no idea dude
what what do you mean I need to go
find bricks no someone has to come
anyway don't he can take care of himself
who
no oh it's good attention do you do did
I ever tell you because it was born
I don't I don't remember oh what is
going on
what did you do
Tim God damn it Tim
one job Tim I went in and got this
myself how how's that possible it was it
was sealed on the Imperial Naval base
and steer guard look you got the money I
got the box what else is there to talk
about I'll give you another thousand
credits to tell me how you got it yeah
he's definitely
how
putting together a team
you just walk in like you belong
takes more than that doesn't it but to
steal from the empire
what do you need a uniform some dirty
hands and an imperial token
they're so proud of themselves they
don't even care
you don't want to get caught with it
well then hang me wouldn't they
Take Me Out bricks Road and hang me in
the Square
would it be the first time would it
isn't that where they hung your father
who are you
I know all about you okay I'm looking
for something more and I think I found
it
I'd like you to come with me
I know you killed two Corpus at Maulana
one and I know they're coming for you
one question
wait another question is how much time
do you have to get out of here not much
don't you want to fight these bastards
for you
chillinips let's go
God it's so tense
[Music]
so cool
look at the community here
damn
[Applause]
he has the sociological details
are you carrying a calm lake why give it
give it to me now
[Music]
rule number one
never carry anything you don't control
nicely done
I forgot there should be some action
scenes in this show
that's just icing on time yeah
these scenes are actionable
just eat a speeder what's the best
option West into town where does that go
under the Old Furnace does it get us out
of here yeah it's the long way around
grab the box up up there they are
is that I put slab charges on the doors
what what when rule number two build
your exit on your way in brace yourself
what a g
whoa damn what is happening
hell of a security system
Contraption with chain choreography yes
oh
Jesus
cover me forget
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a very complicated video game
[Laughter]
a lot of dodging a lot of ducking
come on nice
oh
nice
oh
ouch
if you feel the weight of all this [ __ ]
wow
did he uh oh my God
wait the Box the box is just sitting
back there I thought you were smart what
if he's just one guy left that wouldn't
come here with only four yeah that guy
's Lane oh damn
let's stop right there Tim
what's going on up there I need eyes in
the air no
oh they just leave her there yeah they
brought the building down they've got
explosives hey hold on hold on what do
you mean there there's two of them
heavily off heading your way heavily
armed
take positions
pick them off when they come through
rifle let's go let's find
hang in there Cyril
[Music]
I do like the late the the realism of
this laser blast action like some
sentence I ever thought I'd say
it's like it's such a realism dude
thanks
that's where jaw was really
good Steve doesn't it
shut it that's what a reckoning sounds
like
rise up
oh those are not Jawas they're so cute
though
stops
[Music]
that's when you really want to start to
fret
what happens then
hmm
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh man
you mess with the wrong City such a boss
[Music]
I'm getting out of here
foreign
drop the weapon
it's like the movie Heat
waited all this time for them to finally
meet
how many are you you just learned it
kill him
how many
I'll kill him 12.
it doesn't mean two officers
I swear
just knock him out
[Music]
Reckoning yes you will be weighed down
by scrap metal
oh
God no
again great handling of perspective damn
well who else could it be
everywhere
[Music]
they're getting away
[Music]
okay yeah how did that feeling they're
actually there's a distraction one yeah
yeah Zumba
[Music]
whoa
[Applause]
[Music]
you have to take a notice it didn't kill
you man yeah but you know how Corporate
is
bottom line
[Music]
you got more than you bargained for
today
[Music]
yeah see mirror in the paths that's cool
be carrying your weight
[Music]
oh that's heartbreaking
uh
oh she's just there like look at his
body the whole time there's so much like
drama inflictions
the most heavy harsh place to live yeah
he's the heavy man
[Music]
all right
nice
[Music]
ah there's something so beautiful and
moving about all this yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
well done
rigging a that's beautiful
yeah it was really beautiful
Tony Gilroy is the new Dave filoni
yeah it depends see what happens see how
12 episodes go but yeah let's see
everyone response as much as we're
loving this I'm also under the
impression it might not be for everyone
true then it's very much more deliberate
and harrowing and doesn't have that
that nostalgic hopefulness of it isn't
it's Star Wars yeah it's not as much of
like a fun adventure it doesn't feel as
fantasy filled as sweeping as it does
just yag grungy
and harsh
it's like you can really feel the mud on
everything
for Tim
no ah he's a traitor I know he made his
own bed truly dick
suffered you suffered Tim and then you
made Bix suffer that much more just sit
there looking at your lifeless body
and you knew in that last moment you're
like I I guess I gotta run and save her
so I can make her feel guilty forever
that's the only way
I mean he shouldn't have run
does it feel like there's a bit of a
commentary am I reading too much into
this it feels like there's a bit of an
allegorical commentary with police
brutality
sure and and the way in which I wonder
what's going to happen to Cyril because
it seems like he seems so uncomfortable
with the attitude of everyone around him
and the methods of everyone around him
and now I wonder if he's going to lean
into their way of thinking after seeing
a situation like this and it's like they
have such an ideology and place that
they are following so like I could
totally see it being a rumination on
that to a degree for sure
because you're you are basically
watching Law Enforcement deal with you
know
I mean the thing a lot of times with
writing something like this or anything
a lot of times if if the intent is to
comment on that
sometimes it's much more overt and other
times it's like they do it and like oh I
guess it kind of is so it could just be
an interpretation it just kind of reads
that way to me in this uh in this moment
in time because it doesn't feel like
they're commentating on it yeah to me it
doesn't feel like it's in my face yeah
it feels like it's you can draw it
naturally out of just the experiences of
the characters and the action on the
screen but it doesn't seem like it was
conceived by somebody who said I wanna I
wanna make a police brutality commentary
yeah and I think I can do it with Star
Wars you know it doesn't feel that way
yeah it feels more naturally just yeah
you can interpret that because there's a
lot of Advent characters and it feels
like it deals with like and all these
dudes are white immigration
there's all these qualities and then
finding your Homeland and being taken
away from there there's there are there
are deeper things here but I but I think
what's cool the coolest aspect about
this show to me is that and I was
waiting for like a you know I imagine
it's gonna be like much bigger action
scenes yes because this is you know Tony
Gilroy who yeah
he wasn't the director of what's the
story Rogue one like there was like a
director and then he like supposedly
re-shot like a lot of it yeah Gareth
Edwards directed it and then they
brought
I think it was Tony Gilroy and to retool
a lot of it because I think Dan Kilroy
also worked on it too but yeah I think
Tony is The Unofficial
which read in a way dread or or a
poltergeist yeah yeah or like they
didn't actually yeah he's really love
this direction
really well I I think um I think with
the world that's being brought here it's
like I imagine we'll get bigger action
set pieces and I was kind of waiting for
a bigger action scene before declaring
this because I was waiting to see like
how will the action feel motivated two
will it just be we needed a set piece we
need we need something action based
because like there's there's the opening
of this show but it's not really an
action scene it's like it's like
violence but it's not really an action
scene and this was the first real like
oh this is a set piece yeah dealing with
the Chase and chains and all kinds
Warehouse industrial items explosive I
wouldn't know what this [ __ ] I don't
know exactly know what that is but it's
all I just Fallen apart yeah explosives
the chase on the streets
shootouts and
uh it still felt very motivated by the
plot and by the characters and just feel
like we needed an action scene here you
know you need something that's a bit
rousing you know to propel the character
and a life and death stake situation you
know you throw them in the midst of
danger and then they also have to make a
choice in the moment of time and
a big part of what helps motivate Cassie
cassian's choice is due to the fact that
he's about to get killed him so he has
to go along with this and so I think the
way they even handled the action here
was was really well done because it does
look great it's not the flashiest even
though it does go big but it still it
still feels so much imbued in the
emotion of the show and not so much
about look how cool we can make this so
I wasn't even here going ooh ah because
of the fact that it was it felt just so
gritty and like in World realized with
the kind of muckiness this show has
versus look how extravagant and sweet
this all looks even though it does look
great like the show looks great but I
think the the emotion of the show has
such a good grip on my the way I view it
the lens I see it through so it's very
rare where I'm like whoa yeah I think
that's a good distinction because yeah
you don't you don't get a twirl before
firing the Blaster like like Boba Fett
or something like that like yeah it's
like the action when when you know
things actually pop off and and you know
blasters start firing I like that for
everything they mostly just lean into
the intensity it's like it is cool but
not yeah it's not taking a break to come
up with the neatest shot in order to you
know create a splash page of some kind
like it's really invested in keeping the
momentum and the intensity and the sort
of
um I don't know there's like a dread
that comes out of the suspicion of
everything because you have this really
tense
first meeting with Lutheran and Andor
and them you know feeling each other out
and it's already you know building you
know the geography is good it's like you
know the other team is closing in at
least the backup team and they're
getting to feel each other out and
they've got you know guns aimed at each
other already and then this all goes
down and it feels appropriately like a
mess but also like a thrilling action
set piece as well I thought the whole
choice to use yeah the chains and these
big huge you know whatever you call
those the big spindles that they're on
uh it's like really clever and creative
and also really you know using I thought
they made well to really make ferrics a
character and this felt like you know
you see the chain attached to the one
ship it's like all these different bits
of scrap and just industrial tools are
part of of that so it's like it's really
imaginative while again not you know
taking a break to be like how cool this
is you know it's it's it's it's a really
great Testament I think to when you let
everything kind of speak for itself
um because yeah like there's there's
something about it where you said part
way through like oh yeah there's gonna
be action and it's like they they do
manage to ring that sort of like oh I
didn't even you know no shots have been
fired yet and yet I'm on the edge of my
seat and I'm like nervous you know I
don't exactly know what's gonna happen
and I think that uncertainty too makes
up for
you know the the the the Leaning Less on
you know making it look sleek
yeah because this shows it's a pretty
bleak show it is and it thrusts you into
the the which is like a lot of the
emotions of of our characters here
because it's a bleak world that these
humans live in and it's about the little
Rays of Hope yeah Ray hope you said Star
Wars [ __ ] Star Wars CGI DH Leia
yeah that
at the very end you know you do see that
as desolate and desperate of a situation
this is
that even though you know and or is the
one being Hunter they are a community
working together yeah I love that at
that moment and I love the way they
handled the flashback of how
um
what's her name Marva Marva of of when
Marva
and then young Cassie and how you know
she ended up taking him under her wing
and raising him like the situation that
led to that and how you know it's his
first time with space travel
leaving his home behind
and then as an adult now experiencing
that again leaving his home behind and
you really see that with the way the
community was that is his home as much
as his identity has changed and it's not
the planet he's from this is where his
friends and family are so that betrayal
of Tim even hits a little harder because
you're like come on man look at us all
work together yeah we gotta have each
other
Petty my dude
Scottish people are not looking good on
this show they are not Tim and you got
the other guy oh the the gung-ho dude uh
yeah see like I loved how they handled
that because again they they the way
they've handled the journey that Diego
Lunas and or is going on is
one of lack of purpose and now he's
finding purpose you know
makes me wish I hadn't seen Rogue one I
know a weird feeling because they're
like I wish I wish I didn't we I did
wish her like oh man because
this show breathes so much obviously
it's a show and I think like the way it
breatheses pace and the way I root for
Andor versus like I I don't really root
for Cassian in Rogue one I'm like he's
nice he's Charming I like that but I
don't I'm not like
emotionally invested in Cassian in that
movie
whereas here it like it's so attached to
him in these last
roughly what 90 minutes I'd say 90
minutes of hanging out with him that I I
wish I didn't know where and I wonder if
like by the end it'll make Rogue one
feel more rewarding to watch to see
where it all led to in that Journey that
he went on because now he's finding a
purpose and he's going to be unpacking
because he's just like a Survivor yeah
and and then you got characters like Bix
um who you're seeing because they have
that line for Marva about a reckoning
coming
and it's like oh you guys done messed up
and then you see Bix who's just so
tortured yeah I wonder how she'll come
back in the show
yeah that's a great question because I
feel like we're gonna I feel like the
next episode will Propel us to places
unknown for a while and we might check
out for a little bit with everybody on
ferricks and so I feel like when we see
her again I mean she's definitely going
to be hardened by this or or
I mean yeah like it's already such a
mess of a situation and it's already
risky what Cassian was asking her to do
in the first place like it's it's like
there's yeah I don't know I expect a
good amount of torture for her for her
soul and psyche just because yeah it's
like she didn't want to get involved
with this in the first place she already
had a plan when you know Lutheran was
gonna show up at a later point and I was
like no we got to do this and then Tim
gets in the way and it's yeah it's all
these pieces colliding and I feel like
just the amount of Despair and
and like shock almost in her face at the
end there like that's definitely gonna
germinate into something to to really be
dealt with by that character and I and I
hope you know we get that too because as
much as it is really good at focusing on
Cassian and or
it's also really good at just
expanding to the important people and
even just the people tangentially who he
affects and I love that this episode
took the time to cut back to her and
even though she is you know directly
responding to Tim she's also thinking
about Andor and then you've got his
friend who you know sits down at the bar
and just has a drink and you can tell
what's on his mind and so yeah I think
they've drawn a really nice web of all
these people who clearly care about this
guy who needs to find his place in the
world and I feel like it was a nice I
like the back and forth a lot between
him and Lutheran because
so much of it is questions and so much
of it is like a classic spy or Noir
scene where it's it's just constantly
like can I trust you can I trust you but
that that kind of conclusion that like I
don't even care about the McGuffin the
Box whatever yeah
I think that's great and I love that we
don't actually I I like the choice yeah
I like the choice that he goes back and
tries to get it but ultimately yeah we
don't even see it destroyed fully we
just have to leave it behind and and
it's you I need you are more of the
value as you yeah absolutely and I
thought that was a great hook because
you know that yeah he's going to become
this resistance intelligence officer you
know big instrumental part of Bringing
Down the Death Star but yeah like this
is the real first seed of that you know
the real transition out of the old
scavenger life into something more well
I think what this show is doing so
effective like that's very because
obviously this Lutheran characters uh
very integral to the rise of Rebellion
or or the earlier stages of the
Rebellion
and in order to do that like you gotta
really establish the the emotional
Foundation the core of the of the perp
the why behind to Rebel you know and
it's easy to just go you know Emperor
bad material arm and bad dumb you know
they're bad guys uh it's it's simple to
do that and and what I think this Show's
been doing so well is it's getting you
so honed in on the on the pain of loss
and suffering that one has to go through
due to the universe they now inhabit
because of the empire
and that gives more weight to fight
scenes and to the rise of the Rebellion
because you're like yeah so Rise Up
Stand Up You know because this this is
terrible and it's more effective it is
that effective quality when they are
humans I mean Jedis a lot of them are
human too the Jedi would force Powers
so to just have like your your regular
because because I think that's something
that Rogue one I think helps is that
because they all die in Rogue one it
gives it a sense of finality there's a
there's a finite quality to it and this
seems to kind of lean into that too in
the feels because
again it's about the pain of of losing
like I I you know you see Marva at the
end
um she doesn't even get to say goodbye
and or she just has to hear it over the
Droid in the first part of the episode
yeah sure like they didn't have the best
last conversation yeah and she's in some
ways this is like the last of us of the
Star Wars
like did they she doesn't get to say
goodbye and and she's just standing in
his room
sitting in his room just you know I
imagine like scared
sad there's a whole bunch of emotions
happening with her and then you got Bix
who's just like she doesn't have a
friend and or her
complicated lover situation with him who
also just freaking kind of broke her
heart with betraying
uh there's so there's so much
complication and pain here and I think
the complications all the interwing
interwingling
interwinkling of the intermingling of
these things I think is so fascinating
and
it's cool that you could do a show where
you know where it's gonna land with our
main character but the experience of the
journey is so fulfilling yeah and
engrossing
and that's the mark of a solid ass
prequel you know and one that can make
you or at least makes me invested in an
interested buy and care to a degree
about pretty much every character we
spend time on like as much as even as
much as we rag on Tim and as much as Tim
is a frustrating character like I think
the Ensemble and the way they are all
written is really wonderful and human
because yeah you can see you you
understand where everyone's coming from
and you can kind of fear for where they
will go or you know hope for where they
could turn and two like I'm really I'm
excited to see what happens to Cyril
because even through this episode I kept
thinking to myself like man this is the
first time in a Star Wars thing I can
think of and and you know maybe there's
something I'm overlooking in the moment
but yeah we're like you can have a
person in this position and I like too
that it's not just Imperial officers or
corporate officers they're closer to the
ground and they're closer to the
day-to-day lives of people it seems like
and you're watching Cyril go through all
this and on the one hand you can tell
he's really dedicated to this
poisoned Mission but also you can tell
he's you know overwhelmed by it and and
so I sympathize with him I don't
necessarily root for him but I am
sympathizing and I keep hoping he'll
turn out in some kind of better way but
I feel so I also feel like he's going to
descend heavily and it's like I I care
about that more than just like oh an
actor I like is is chewing the scenery
right now which I feel like a lot of the
Empire the uh empirical you know Heavies
can be like you know yeah good point um
and so yeah just like they give that
perspective to everybody and yeah even
characters like Bix or like Marvin like
I actually care to check in with you and
it doesn't feel like anyone's being
shoved in my face you know it's it's it
feels like a real world
and selling Skarsgard so good at doing
his Stellan scars
you can do it throwing everything away
in the coolest way possible he can be
like so villainous and he could be such
a good guy and he could he could play
tough people he could play
pitiful losers like I've seen this guy
do everything and he's so natural
there's a lot of stone Skarsgard
performances I have not seen but I've
seen such a variety of stone scars cards
yeah I often forget like oh yeah you
were like so talented like yeah like you
have that demeanor in that voice that is
so striking that you would be fooled
into thinking he's playing the same
person all the time
it's funny that he and mads Mickelson
should both be in this corner of the
Star Wars
an office is a good guy though and Rogue
one no he's usually a bad guy yeah but
true but he brings a mads mickelsoninus
wherever he goes and that can be a bad
guy heavy it can be a good guy it can be
just a regular struggle in human with
alcoholism I've heard of that recent
movie he did
and two I mean a big hats off I think as
well to Fiona Shaw because like you know
I think a lot of people are used to
seeing her in Harry Potter but she's
been around so long and I love when they
give actors and actresses you know
gilroyed British or something because it
seems like she's a British heavy show I
know I don't think he's British I I'm I
would love to know because this feels
like such a British show yeah it really
does and like Fiona Shaw like hats off
to her because I think she she embodies
I loved the flashback and the whole time
Jump thing it's like you see her in the
present and she comes across like oh
yeah it's your it's your surrogate mom
and she lives at home and and you know
she's kind of limited mobility and then
you see her in the younger uh days when
they're raiding the the ship and it's
like oh damn like yeah I believe you
also is like a you know Scavenging space
Adventurer of some kind and uh and yeah
it's I love unexpected performances like
that and uh I think it's working really
nicely here and too like you you brought
up with the whole you know law
enforcement brutality angle too she says
that thing about like the ship crash
landed here like you know no matter what
you guys did they're gonna be on you and
you guys are going to pay the
consequences for this no matter what so
so I think yeah there's a there's
definitely those themes oh yeah I mean
like when they shoot Tim yeah they
didn't have to do that they knew they
they could read that situation there's
like eight of them with a neutralized
yeah
and then and then the punishment is give
me your gun and go warm up the ship yeah
or hit him you know you're on shift Duty
now you didn't have to kill him yeah you
just have to shoot him in the chest yeah
yeah I wonder if they he's just like
yeah if they if Tim was a black guy then
people would be like just broke
a shoving shouts if Tim was black then
the whole unit would have crowded around
him and just kept on him
and then we would be having more
conversations right now
but yeah no they they I think they are
doing really nicely to to give to me
it's the best of all worlds it's like
yes this is a darker more mature angle
on a Star Wars story but it has a lot of
themes and ideas and Aesthetics that
still feel very akin to and fitting of a
Star Wars story but at the same time
touch over under real life in a way that
doesn't feel like you know canned or
like hey this was a note from the studio
that we need to do this yeah you know
well it feels like a quite a mature step
for Star Wars and I can feel this one
that doesn't feel like
it doesn't feel like Disney it does it
and it's it fascinates me to no end that
that Tony Gilroy apparently is is so
passionate like they said like he was
really passionate about this project and
you know it's like you know Tony Gilroy
from writing Bourne movies and Michael
Clayton and things that are much more
you know down to earth and much more
about the writing and about paying
attention
and so I I love that he's apparently so
passionate about this because it really
shows in the crafting of everything all
around well I I mean I don't think um
you know Toby Henderson or whatever his
name is
I get his name wrong
Todd Haynes Toby Haynes no absolutely
because the directing on these it's been
all three episodes thus far he's
directed and and that handheld so
handheld so handheld sets you wouldn't
want that cameraman to feel like he's
having a hard time
I want my cameraman's arms to be
throbbing at the end of each take all
right now that's in the editing system
can we add a handheld effect more to
this thing how much more can we shake
this thing up please I'm talking double
boards
yeah yeah no I mean that that and and
again too yeah the dedication like you I
I wonder how you know they choose how
many directors do whatever whatever but
whenever I see a particular director's
name on several episodes I'm like okay
then you also yeah must have been quite
invested in this director of like a
first episode or first couple is so
crucial to setting the stage and the
tone for what other directors will
eventually kind of follow yeah where
they lack creative freedom
we're not coming to you look established
don't mix it up too much you can do some
shots that you really like careful
Robert Rodriguez
but I wonder if if maybe on the fourth
one we might get a switch up or if it'll
be Toby like 12 episodes a lot for one
director but
but I'm here for it either way Mike
Flanagan did all of hunting a hill house
and that's true those are all like
hour-long I want to make yourself
all on the same topic all right guys
well thanks for being here I'm really
loving this show so far so good I'm
excited to see what the rest of the
journey entail makes sense now knowing
where this episode ends whether we
release the three on the day of yeah
yeah because because yeah now it's like
we're setting this is like the setup
we're off on the adventure now a very
very long setup part of me thinks you
should have just been one 90 minute
episode
two hour Premiere event it could have
been 90 minute episode because it kind
of ends like other than a third one they
all kind of end like oh it's over okay
like like kind of tweak some of the
editing of the ending
[Music]
stories they told per episode yeah this
feels like chapter one or a prologue of
the same specific story they wanted to
tell over these three episodes so yeah
but yeah still great [ __ ] I mean it's a
minor complaint
um
it's not even really complaints just
like
yeah it's like you could have done this
and I wouldn't have complained yeah I
have got the attention span for that but
thank you for being here we'll catch you
all soon people
foreign